I went back to the gym recently after
yeah yeah yeah and uh you know and like
the the local gym I I went to like you
can you know they're obviously like oh
you can like use the app to see like how
many people are at the gym right now in
case you don't want to be like you know
yeah in case like the Gym's like full or
anything or you don't you know your
machines aren't available I'm like oh
that's great that's fantastic so before
I leave the house I go okay let's see
how many people are there and I usually
try to go like during the night because
that's when people yeah that's when it's
empty yeah so I went in and the gym I go
to split into two floors and it's like
the free weights are on one floor and
then the machines are on another floor
and it's and on the map it shows you
like okay there are this many people on
this floor there's many people on this
floor so one of the nights I was like oh
okay cool there's no one in the free
weights room so I'll just go there empty
the entire night right but I don't know
if this is the same with the gym you
guys go to but like now they've made it
so that if you're on like a cardio like
like a running machine or like a bike or
anything you don't have to wear a mask
oh not on my gym you still have to wear
them oh really okay so in my gym it's
like if you're on the running machine or
you're on like a bicycle like any cardio
stuff so that you can [ __ ] breathe
properly yeah you can take the mask off
but if you're on a machine or you're in
Freer weights you have to have a mask
they're so so dumb that Anytime Fitness
at least one near me you still have to
wear a mask on the cardio oh really and
like some people do it yeah
bro I'm I'm like nah bro yeah okay I go
in the corner I look at the wall and I'm
like yeah please just don't bother me
because I can't run the message yeah
it's the same but like so so I was like
all right I'll just go to the freeway
term whatever right it's empty as [ __ ]
right and you have to wear a mask even
in the free weights room right yeah but
I'm like it's like 10 p.m I know no
one's gonna come in no one's here yeah
so [ __ ] it I'll just take the mask off
so I can actually breathe right
just yesterday I get this text from the
gym no a text a text an automated
message text that basically reads uh
yeah so there have been reports that uh
you were at the gym uh on this day at
this time not wearing a mom no and I'm
like and are you serious yeah and it was
like and it was like uh you know we uh
you know we've revoked your credit card
accident
you're now not allowed to spend you're
on that Blacklist
and no basically it was like dystopian
it was so like it was so passive
aggressive too because it was like
you're not in trouble but it's just like
a warning you know it's like we we
require all uh you know gym goers to
wear a mask where it's necessary but and
I'm like
bro this room was empty who am I gonna
infect yeah yeah I mean was there
someone who reports to you or did was
there someone who was like who was like
looking on the security probably someone
who just like the next day went on to
the security camera and was like oh this
[ __ ] Foreigner's not wearing a mask
imma send a passive aggressive tweet to
them okay maybe they have ai that can
tell when you're not wearing a mask
probably I need to turn on the lights in
the back okay oh [ __ ] oh yeah we are
dumb and forgot to turn on our purple
lights
I don't think any of us are anti-mask
but I think when it comes to exercise I
think you know there should be some
leeway there where it's like hey
especially when you're doing cardio yeah
I just yeah and it is annoying that at
least Anytime Fitness in Japan is
doesn't well at least there's like
[ __ ] millions of signs right yeah
saying don't worry but most people I've
seen don't some people do it's weird
seeing who does and doesn't in Japan
right as Foreigner it's like all right
people expect me to not follow the rules
and it's like whatever but it's weird
it's odd seeing which Japanese people uh
follow the rules and I've noticed the
more ripped someone is in the gym in
Japan the less likely they are to wear
their mask I'm not kidding they're
absolutely who's gonna tell them
who's gonna stop no kidding you the
absolute Giga chat's in the gym don't
wear masks I'm not this is not this is
okay
me being like do real men don't wear
it's like I've just noticed that the
more rips someone is in Japan the more
the mess might be like down here or down
here
I know you know and people who tend to
be more timid I've noticed that yeah
it's weird that's weird I've noticed
that I'm not saying that like Google
shreds don't worry I don't that's
probably why I got the text message
because the guy looked at the security
camera I'm like this [ __ ] skinny
[ __ ]
I'm gonna [ __ ] up his social credit
scores
it must be AI That's counting how many
people are in there she's pretty easy so
it might be AI That's just if it's an
automated message yeah but like I don't
know it's just like I've never gotten a
message like that and I was just like
dumb fan I'm like first of all there was
no one there so how the [ __ ] did they
know and second I'm like okay I get it
if there was like you know other people
in the room right that are in close
vicinity but for one this is an empty
ass room it was empty the entire time I
was there like before I came after I
left no one ever came in no one even
came close also what the [ __ ] is the
point of there being five air purifiers
in this tiny room yeah I mean like I
feel like Japan is like Japan's like
I've because I know this is with a few
places now where Japan's at this point
where it's kind of like in this limbo
phase where people don't know yeah yeah
people don't know whether to take you
know the same Corona precautions
whether to stick with them or not
because I've noticed some establishment
like you go to like restaurants and
stuff and all the signs are still up
over like the same like covid
precautions that would like there deep
during the pandemic were the
establishments follow them or not is
completely a coin flip yeah right now
you know which thing I I really want to
die and I hope this never I just want
this to stop right you only go to a
restaurant or a cafe yeah and they have
this in Japan I don't think they did
this anywhere else they had the screen
dividing you and your friend yeah yeah
yeah yeah and so I hate that and so I to
me like again I'm I'm all for taking
precautions to separate you from other
customers because yeah you didn't come
in with them but if you come in with say
like uh someone you're dating or your
partner who you're married to yeah and
then they put this screen in between you
both in my head I'm like what is this
like I don't understand it's like I'm
visiting my partner in jail you know
that's what it feels like honey
[Applause]
again I don't if that was like fine but
it's like if I want to share food it
becomes impossible oh yeah because yeah
yeah and don't I swear to God if you
touch it in Japan they freak out yeah
because you know maybe you have a big
enough table where you're like ah [ __ ]
it you move it and then like yeah
and they're like what are you doing put
it back and it's like oh what I mean he
just committed Warfare it's weird though
I know I've been in other restaurants
where they'll be they'll just literally
see you coming together and they'll just
move it for you yeah it's so bizarre and
it it feels like incredibly inconsistent
which is what makes it annoying yeah
yeah and and you know like we did um I
uh I had my fourth shot recently I don't
even know if America's doing fourth
shots right or only is the UK doing
fourth shot I have no idea it's covered
boosters well I I you know Japan became
my mail and it was like you should do it
and I was like fine I'll go and do it
yeah yeah why not yeah yeah who doesn't
want more protection sure just
collecting them all right yeah
and so I go and um get this thing I sit
down and uh this elderly guy starts
talking to me
um in Japanese but then he starts he
asks me if I speak English and I was
like oh yeah I speak English then he
starts speaking to me in like fluent
English and he's like he's like 70
nearly 80 I think yeah that's like the
shiny Pokemon of Japan yeah
smoothest most awesome pronunciation of
English ever and I was like oh wow let
me started talking and you know you're
having a good time we're like laughing
joking and then they they're like some
posting camera was like stop talking
reasons you could be spreading it I'm
like are we still at that stage where
we're worried about this like we're
wearing masks like is this apparently
we're like whispering to each other and
then he get this old man goes yeah
Japan is too strict sometimes
I'm an old Japanese people are so
frustrated he was like shaking his head
when she told him off it was so funny I
was like oh man this guy is like he's
the energy of a young person yeah that's
probably why I can speak English right
yeah he's the voice of reasons obviously
if an old Japanese guy speaks English
they've they've traveled around you know
what's up it's it's um it's interesting
I mean it's weird seeing which aspects
of covert precautions they cling on to
yeah yeah and I don't necessarily feel
like it's of any
any real impact more of maybe like a
comfort thing yeah I don't really
understand a lot of the thought process
I mean it's gotten to the point right
now where I think at this stage in the
pandemic a lot of a lot of the
establishments that do these kind of
kind of things is kind of more like
Theater which is quite sure which is
like which is why some people choose to
do it some people would choose not to
enforce it and it's kind of like
dependent on the establishment because
like yeah the I went to a restaurant the
other day where they still had the
screen like like uh disconnecting me and
whoever you're sitting down with yeah
and you know if you just ask them hey
can we remove this they were like
they'll just go okay yeah yeah okay okay
sometimes they do sometimes they do
sometimes they do not want they are like
absolutely but that's the thing right
it's like it would be less frustrating
if they're at least consistent with it
if like if if it was like in the heart
of the pandemic where it's like there
was no [ __ ] there was no excuse It's
like this is this this is this and these
are the steps you want to take then it's
like okay well there's nothing I can do
about it I might as well live with it
yeah but like now as you said it's like
there are sometimes where I walk into
like a company right and like one
company you know I might be like oh [ __ ]
I forgot my mask they won't say anything
another one I walk in without my mask
and they just follow the freak the [ __ ]
out and I'm like can you at least be
consistent with this [ __ ] yeah yeah I
went into a combini to buy a mask so I
lost my mess and then they were freaking
out yeah yeah I was like oh no no I'm
buying a mess yeah and they were like
how do we what is this protocol how do
we ah I can see the like gears turning
yeah like oh no because you know often
times yeah your mask yeah it's like yeah
it's like you just put your mess in your
pocket on it maybe it fell out or you
know you dropped it somewhere you put it
in the car you know you've got to buy a
new mask yeah yeah it's like dude I'm
just buying a mess man chill out yeah
like I'm trying to follow and adhere to
the rules but sometimes it's like it's
it feels like you said it feels more
like theater and it's in it's well I I
think it's it's also compounded by the
fact that you know the country's open
now and there's no way to distinguish us
between like people who have lived here
during the pandemic and tourists you
know what I mean so it's it's kind of
I've because I've noticed this a lot
where before you know people kind of
treated you all the same
um because they knew you know you you
knew kind of like the rules here because
you must have been living here right
yeah but now they must come in with the
Assumption of you just came in this
country yesterday you don't know
anything you know what I mean and I I've
noticed that subtle like yeah Behavior
shift within like the past few weeks